I will be giving this Saturday the
keynote address at the grassroots radio
conference in Rochester New York I hope
you'll join me there I've been going to
this conference off and on for many
years I remember going once years ago in
Humboldt County California up there
about four hours roughly four hours
North fret as I recall from San
Francisco a real cannabis country very
interesting to see that another time I
went to the grassroots radio conference
in Kansas City Missouri got some great
barbecue met some great people and this
year the conference is in Rochester New
York at I will be speaking at 4:00 p.m.
local time
that's eastern time on Saturday it is a
media conference so the panels and the
sessions are mostly based around media
and independent media it's really great
stuff and it would be great for you to
attend the entire conference but I've
also asked the GRC to make tickets
available just to the keynote if people
want to come and see that it's only 10
bucks I'm guessing there's another
dollar or so service charge or something
like that 4 p.m. this Saturday October
what is the date is the the 4th right no
the 5th Saturday is the 5th I believe
man I'm getting today is the 1st 2nd 3rd
4th yeah whatever the date is on
Saturday that's the date and all the
info is at grassroots radio conference
dot org I would love to see you there I
will speak about media I will speak
about fake news attacks on media and all
of that stuff and then there will be an
opportunity to ask questions as well
great times to be had by all
I've never been to Rochester so I'm
looking forward to it and once again the
website where you can find all of the
information is grassroots radio
conference dot org